Hosea 6 1 and 2. Do you think maybe we
are nearing the end of the second day?
If not, why?
Every day is closer to the end of the
second day because we're much closer to
the return of Jesus than we were 2,000
years ago. Of course, you're nearer. You
think you're further away or as time
goes by, we're approaching the second
coming of our Lord Jesus
more and more and it's closer and closer
with each passing day. So obviously the
second day is about to end but when
exactly I don't know. Yeah. Well the
reason why I asked cuz I know you're
kind of questionable is because I think
because of the return of the Jews to
their homeland. Maybe that's the revive
them being revived if is it not? Well no
they're not revived because you have
hundreds of thousands of Jews who
believe in Jesus. Praise the Lord. But
the government itself is a government
that's anti- good, antirist, anti-Bible.
When I say Bible, the New Testament. So
that's another thing which Christians
need to stop. Let me now comment on
that. And I need you to hear me out. My
own understanding of end time prophecy.
And I'll tell you why. Because of my
understanding of Zechariah chapters
12-4. Zechariah 12 to 14. You don't need
to turn there, brother. I can hear you
flip the pages. There goes my ears. You
don't need to read it. I'm just going to
mention it. I believe. Okay. Zechariah
chapters 12, 13, and 14. Read them. If
you properly read those passages, the
New Testament says those passages will
be fulfilled at Jesus's second coming.
Because in Zechariah 14, it concludes
with Jehovah landing on the Mount of
Olives, his physical feet splitting the
Mount of Olives as he comes with his
holy ones to reign in Jerusalem when he
destroys the armies that gather against
Jerusalem. The New Testament takes that
and applies it to the second coming of
Jesus. Because in Acts 1:es 9-12, it
says that Jesus physically ascended from
the Mount of Olives in a cloud and
disappeared from their sight. The angel
said the way he left is the way he'll
return. So he's going to return to the
Mount of Olives physically like he left
physically, but that's second coming.
But his return will be accompanied by
his holy ones, his saints. 1
Thessalonians chapter
3:13. 1 Thessalonians chapter 3:13. That
means Zechariah 14 will be literally
physically fulfilled when Jehovah Jesus
descends physically upon the Mount of
Olives with his feet and splits it in
half. But according to Zechariah 14,
that takes place at the latter days when
the nations gather against the Jews in
Jerusalem. Well, that could not have
ever happened at any point in history
until the Jews were back in the land.
And that happened in 1948. So with that
said, let me repeat everyone understand.
I do believe the Jews returning to
Israel was a fulfillment of prophecy
leading to the physical return of
Christ. I know Christians disagree with
me. Yeah. Now I know Christians disagree
with me. But with that said, that
doesn't mean that the government is
pleasing to God. That doesn't mean the
Jews are pleasing to God any more than
any nation that God grants the power to
rule must be pleasing to God. After all,
according to Daniel 2, let me give you
the verses. Daniel 2, write them down.
Daniel 2:es
37-38. Daniel 2 37- 38. Daniel 4:es 24-
26 Daniel 4:es 24- 26 Daniel
4:es 31-32 Daniel 4:es
31-32 and Daniel 4 Daniel
4:es 34-37 Daniel 4:es 34-37 all of
those passages say God is the one who
chooses which king will rule over what
kingdom and which king will be
triumphant and supreme over other kings.
It's all in God's hand. That means it is
God who's allowing the Saudi Arabians to
rule Arabia, though they're Muslims. It
is God who's allowing the Iranians to
control Iran, though they're a Shia
Muslim. Any government that is ruling,
it's because God is allowing them to
rule. But it doesn't mean that God is
pleased with any of them.
Gotcha. Right? Okay. With that said, now
pay attention now. With that said, just
because God allowed the Jews to return
to the land, that doesn't mean it's
because he's pleased with them. In fact,
if you go to Ezekiel 36, Ezekiel 36 and
read 20 to 23, God telling the Jews when
he's going to bring them back from
Babylon into the land because this was
in Babylonian captivity. He goes, "Don't
think I'm doing it because you're
righteous." It's there. Ezekiel 36
20-23. He says it. He says, "It's not
because your righteousness." In fact, he
says it's the opposite. You have
embarrassed me. You have shamed me.
You've dishonored me more so than anyone
among the nations. So why am I bringing
you back? For my glory, for my honor,
for my zeal. What does that mean? Now, I
need you to understand this, guys. I
hope you're listening. I hope you're
listening. God is saying, "I'm bringing
you back not because you're righteous,
you're wicked, you're pathetic. I'm
bringing you back for my glory and honor
my zale my zeal. He even says to them,
you have shamed me. You have profained
me. You have blasphemy me more than
anyone among the nations. So then God,
why are you bringing him back? Now let
me explain this as you're flipping the
pages, which you need to stop doing so
you can listen. Are you listening? Yeah,
I'm listening. Stop flipping pages. I
keep hearing pages flipping. You're
killing me. Okay, here. I'm driving.
Okay, that's good. Just don't drive me
crazy. Now here, listen to this. What
does God mean? If you don't understand
the ancient historical, cultural
background of the Bible, every kingdom
believed they had gods or goddesses
reigning over them and empowering them.
Keep this in mind. And if you want proof
of it, read Isaiah 36 and Isaiah 37.
Those two chapters in full. Isaiah 36
and Isaiah 37. Read those chapters in
full. There you're gonna see my stupid
ancestors, the Assyrians, Ashariah.
During the reign of San Assyrians, you
know, he's mentioned in the Bible.
Sanakarb Sanakarb is Sanub. He sent the
Rupshaka, the leader of the army of
Assyria
to to Judah on Jerusalem, I'm sorry,
Jerusalem, the capital of Judah, where
King Hezekiah was reigning from. And
they surrounded Jerusalem. The ruptak
and his stupidity says, "Look, don't
think your god can deliver you out of
the hand of my king. Look at all the
other nations. Which of their gods was
able to deliver their people from the
hands of my king?" And because of that
blasphemy, God says, "I'm going to send
these back the way they came." And even
archaeology confirms the historical
accuracy of this event. We found the
san prism where sanak even mentions by
the way archaeology has confirmed this.
Google
san prism there he recounts how he took
about 46 fortified cities of Judah and
he hemmed the king of Judah in in
Jerusalem. But then he says instead of
capturing the capital he went back which
was unusual unheard of. Why? Because
Zanakarb would also take over the
capital of each city that he attacked.
But for some reason, he didn't capture
Jerusalem, but it said he went back the
way he came without taking it captive.
Perfect archeological confirmation of
the
Bible. Now, why am I mentioning
this? So far, you all of you are you all
you guys following
me? You I'm not losing any of you. You
understood everything I'm saying. I'm
saying to trying to say it as fast as I
can but slow enough that you get it.
Okay. Now, why am I mentioning this?
Because kingdoms thought they were not
just fighting kingdoms but the gods and
the goddesses. So when I went to battle,
if I'm a Syrian and I went to battle
with the
Egyptian, my understanding and the
understanding Egyptians is it's the
battle of the gods. Which of the gods
will defeat the other god? So if the
Assyrian kingdom defeated Egyptian
Egyptians, that was a sign. My god
defeated your god. Your god wasn't
strong enough to defeat my god. That was
their mindset. Everyone with me there.
Before I move on, I know you're getting
it. Everyone else, you got it? Because
this question he asked you was an
excellent question.
Okay, if you got it, let me explain the
significance. So what do you think the
pagans assumed? What do you think the
pagans thought every time they defeated
the Jews and them? Oh, our gods are
better than Yahweh, stronger than
Yahweh, and defeated Yahweh in battle.
That's what they thought. That's why
That's why Yahweh said That's why Yahweh
said, "Because of your filthy, wicked
sins, you've let me no choice but
allowed the pagans to beat you into
repentance." But they don't see it as me
sending them in my power to defeat you
because they couldn't touch you. They
actually think it's their gods defeating
me. And so because of your sin, you put
me in a
situation where the nations are now
blaspheing me because they think their
gods are better than me and defeating me
cuz they don't think and they don't
believe that it's me sending them and
give me the power to defeat you.
Otherwise, they couldn't touch you. So
now I have to arise for my glory and
vindicate my honor and their sight so
they don't think they're gods that are
better than me. So they know that I am
God and there is no God who can confront
me. That's why I have to now bring you
back. It's exactly what Zachchariah was
saying. Basically God removing his hand
of protection on him. Everyone got why
God is doing that. So what's the point?
God is saying I'm not bringing you back
cuz you're good and righteous. I'm
bringing you back in spite of you being
filthy and wicked because people
associate me with you talking about time
Ezekiel. So every time you get defeated
they think their god beat me. Now I have
to show them I am almighty God. There is
no God who can stand before me because I
want them to realize I alone am the God
worthy of their worship and they must
worship me to be saved. So I have to now
destroy their armies and bring you back
for that reason.
So what's the point? How does that tie
in with the modern state of Israel?
Don't assume because the Jews became a
nation that God is pleased with them.
The New Testament is crystal clear. The
people of
God is the church of Jesus Christ. If
you're an ethnic Jew and you believe in
Jesus, you're part of the church, the
true Israel, the true body of Christ,
the true bride of Christ. If you're an
ethnic Jew and you reject Jesus, you are
cut off and you're not chosen. There are
not two chosen peoples. There's only
one, the church of Jesus Christ. So when
Jesus restores the Jews, he's making
them part of the church. It's no longer
the nation of Israel that's God's
covenant people. It's the church that's
God's covenant people. And if you're an
Israelite, you better be a member of
that church. Otherwise, you're not part
of his covenant community.
Amen. Okay. Yeah, I see it. That'll be
the true revival then. Yes. When they're
engrafted in and made part of the church
of Jesus Christ.
Beautiful. Okay. Did that make sense?
Man, this book is so alive, man. It's
alive. It's supernatural. And it's
amazingly in-depth. Incredible.